überall sollen jetzt die Gas und
Ölheizungen raus und die neue
Zukunftstechnologie ist die Wärmepumpe
wenn man mit irgendeinem Experten der
sich ein bisschen den Bereich auskennt
redet dann erfährt man überall das
Gleiche wärmepumpen sind sicher eine
sinnvolle Technologie für moderne
Niedrigenergiehäuser überhaupt keine
Frage für alte
ältere weniger gedämmte Gebäude mit
älteren Heizungsanlagen sind Wärmepumpen
einfach völlig ineffizient man kriegt
das Haus nicht warm die Energiekosten
explodieren das heißt man muss nicht nur
die teure Wärmepumpe einbauen man muss
eigentlich sein ganzes Haus umbauen man
muss dämmen man muss die Heizung umbauen
und da sind reden wir über Kosten in der
Richtung von mehreren 100.000 € ganz
schnell und die haben nur mal die
wenigsten Bürger im sparstrom aber wir
müssen Ausnahmen machen nämlich
Ausnahmen für Pflegeheime und
Krankenhäuser damit die nicht in ihrer
Existenz bedroht werden müssen muss es
so sein dass bei Pflegeheim und
Krankenhäusern also dass die nicht ihre
Gas und Ölheizung verschrotten müssen
weil sonst werden sie in ihrer Existenz
bedroht